it's time to take a walk on the wild
side as we continue our summer fun
series
yes bianca holmen live at the lion
habitat over in henderson where families
can see
exotic animals very up close and
personal good morning bianca
oh man hey good morning alex good
morning john yeah i heard you alex
he's right here oh my gosh exactly we've
made our way through the savannah
in the jeep i'm here with denise
souffron who helped us navigate
all of our all the way to see bentley
tell us for those who don't know about
the lion habitat ranch here in here in
henderson so we're home to 30 lions and
also some rescued birds and then
of course our giraffe ozzy here our
ambassador giraffe
tell us about these lions here uh
because people may think are they from
the wild
no they actually were born in human care
so the cats were either born on property
or came from other facilities and then
the other animals for the most part here
are rescues
but ozzie actually came to us from
another zaa accredited facility
all right ozzy the giraffe and also
tells these lions 500 pounds because
they're eating right now what is he
munching on for breakfast
um so towards me it's from a company
called nebraska they provide for zoo
diets all around the united states and
it's actually fortified with all the
vitamins and nutrients that they need
and the males will eat anywhere between
seven and a half to twelve pounds a day
and the females eat anywhere between
five
and seven and a half pounds a day you
know it's so incredible to see them up
close because they
are huge like we you when you see it on
tv they don't look that big you're like
oh they look
no i mean they look big but to see it up
close to feel their energy up close it's
it's really undescribable and also tell
us is he going to start yet
they're going to start meowing a roaring
rather roaring
tell us why it's so important to have a
place like this for our animals
we want to inspire a connection for the
animals it's one thing to see the cats
and like
all the animals on tv but it's another
thing to see and experience them in
person because we really want people to
take a part in conservation either
locally or internationally
yeah and can you all hear that
i don't know if you all can hear their
their roaring right now
and that just to me tell us what it
means when they're roaring so they're
actually talking to each other they're
just kind of communicating each other's
territory so each enclosure is their own
territory they're saying hey i'm here
you shouldn't be to the other lions on
property
and we've learned so much here you guys
got to go to our facebook page because
we did a facebook live we got to see
behind the scenes in the aussie space
we got to see the emus yes
we got to see the evils the ostriches
the birds they have so much here
for you all to learn and see up close
and personal
okay okay he's eating right now we're
gonna let him eat in peace
we're gonna let him have his breakfast
and peas with his morning coffee
back to you guys in the studio oh my god
alex you just jumped in your chair i did
bianca that glass is really clean
so at first i thought he was on the back
of your jeep
oh okay yeah i know there's glass here
you guys there's
there's a little protection all right
yeah that is such a beautiful lion
bianca and you're right you don't know
until you see it in person and feel
their energy
yeah it's just beautiful it's gorgeous
stuff and a lot of fun to go check out
bianca thank you very much and uh
yeah tell the lions to keep their voices
down would you please people are trying
to sleep
you can hear them five miles away john
five miles
wow yeah they wake people up denise was
telling me they get emails saying
oh we heard we heard the lions at four
in the morning
how about that for a wake-up call
instead of a rooster
a rooster right instead of a rooster how
about you wake up to bentley
marking his territory that'll get you
out of bed like am i in the sahara with
mine
where am i here wow thanks bianca all
right bianca
well you go ahead and uh get on out of
there as well